effectivement que burkin il ya pas de
rotation religieuse ça malheureusement
c'est maladroit parce que c'est faux
mais au-delà de ça quand audi la liberté
notamment des femmes c'est de faire ce
qu'on veut non quand on vit en société
la liberté c'est de ne pas choquer les
autres c'est ça dont une piscine faites
ce que vous voulez mais dans une piscine
municipale ont fait pas ce qu'on veut
vous n'arrivez pas en burqini on
n'arrive pas à laisser un nul 6-6
j'arrivais à poil j'arrive pas potable
tu vois ce que je veux dire on ne fait
pas ce qu'on veut c'est à chaque fois la
liberté je peux faire n'importe quoi je
peux arriver directement ou déguisés je
peux arriver à pois je peux arriver les
seins nus piscine municipale environ
société en société on doit faire en
sorte de ne choquer personne cohérent si
vous choquer quelqu'un par définition
c'est est ce qu'un souci c'est pourquoi
ils vont avec ce raisonnement il ya plus
de caricature un peu ce que j'ai non
parce qu'avec votre raisonnement on n'a
pas le droit de l'un des caricatures si
vous dites on a droit de choquer
personne la france est un pays où on
peut être choqué par les opinions des
autres mais il ya ce que j'appelle les
moeurs les c'est pour ça le bikini que
vous le vouliez ou pas c'est un symbole
islamistes le but recherché le birkin et
ses deux sabots les islamistes armés par
ailleurs maire voudrait vous poser une
question très très fraternelle joël si
vous voulez moi ce qui m'embête c'est
que vous voyez bien effectivement que ça
heurte une majorité de nos concitoyens y
compris des musulmans je leur répète les
femmes d'accord ça choque et ça a
beaucoup de gens voulaient mais daniel
j'ai dit il ya des tonnes de pays où on
pousse et encourager
je veux dire la france est effectivement
ce pays singulier moi je pense que ce
que vous avez en échange c'est une
merveille à cette une c'est un cadeau
merveilleux d'entrer dans la communauté
politique française
non mais moi j'ai pu beaucoup aidé à
mettre les vies auraient remplacement
qui sert à rien à part essayer de faire
peur aux gens voilà ma part emplacement
à l'indic de l'or qui dit si c'est ce
qu'elle sous-entend a dit attention si
de demain la société ressemblera cette c
vous dites que le ben oui alors que les
gens mais se heurtent eux qui à part les
gens qui ont peur
de la différence bastille pas non pardon
mais avec maintenant un brasseur 80
quand on est français puisqu'elle son
encontre guillaume grimpeur pur parle de
sondage il ya là bien mais je n'entends
le burqini c'est un progrès social les
femmes du rhdp
il ya peut-être beaucoup de femmes
aujourd'hui mais qui ne se sentent pas à
l'aise d'aller à la piscine parce
qu'elles ne veulent pas se dénuder
partiellement et qui aujourd'hui grâce
aux burqini pourront à la peine donc oui
c'est une avancée sociale gorille du
grand emplacement dans le piémont
alors que moi je
vous dis benhaim s'agira d'une question
radia gilles verdez bea daniel moreau
dehors
ne fait pas semblant de tomber dans le
piège des laxatifs reid eric piolle qui
en fait fait juste un truc électoraliste
il est parce que il estime que ça va lui
rapporter des voix en fait il en a rien
à faire de mieux son de faire grise mine
il se dit simplement que ça peut lui
rapporter des voix et nous on est
bêtement tous collectivement tombé dans
un piège qui d'un côté nous mais
l'extrême droite qui manipulent de
l'autre côté nous mais l'extrême gauche
qui manipulent au milieu nous mais
l'islam radical qui se frottent les
mains et qui est les grands perdants de
tout ça sont les femmes musulmanes si on
fait elle leur disent simplement fichez
nous la paix celle qui veut lever sur
qu'est-ce qui te gêne dans cette de voir
une femme en bikini c'est parce que
c'est un joueur aurait fait de verser à
l'avancé du féminisme ce n'est pas une
avancée du féminisme